and a lot of women in my culture they
don't work they just sort of stay at
home and the man goes out and gets the
money and they just raise the kids
obviously we've moved on from that but I
still hold those values in the sense
that I'm okay to submit to my man when
the time is right or when I feel the
time is right but the whole point is
that's that's not submission is when you
feel I mean we're women we change our
opinions every goddamn day we don't even
know what we want half the time so it's
like if you if if I if I employ
blessings and I say blessing turn this
camera angle on or I do do this do this
and at the end of the day I have the
final say and and that's kind of how it
is should be anyways when you're
submitting to a guy
so